el nuevo gabinete peruano nombrado por
francisco sagasti será liderado por una
mujer el gobierno de transición ha sido
catalogado como técnico prudente en lo
económico y con una amplia participación
femenina la nueva primera ministra es
violeta bermúdez
una abogada feminista con experiencia en
gobierno y derechos humanos el día en
que no sea noticia que una mujer asume
un cargo un ministerio un tribunal
ese día habremos logrado la igualdad
mientras siga siendo noticia es que las
cosas no están tan bien en total son 8
mujeres en el nuevo gabinete de las
cuales 3 liberarán los primeros cargos
en orden de precedencia del gobierno a
nivel de relaciones internacionales la
nueva ministra de estado o cancilleres
esther astete fue embajadora de la
nación suramericana en méxico y ecuador
y representante permanente del país ante
organismos internacionales en ginebra
nuria esparch es la primera mujer en la
historia en asumir el ministerio de
defensa de perú es patches abogada ocupó
el cargo de viceministra de recursos
para la defensa y tiene experiencia en
temas de poblaciones vulnerables se suma
a la lista waldo mendoza quien a partir
de la fecha es el nuevo ministro de
finanzas entonces es economista fue
miembro del consejo directivo del banco
central reserva y docente porte
de aislamiento social durante la crisis
sanitaria federico tenorio juramento
como ministro de agricultura de forma
virtual tenorio es licenciado en
administración pública y se desempeñaba
como director ejecutivo de una ong
dedicada al desarrollo rural
con cierto hartazgo la población exige
en las calles un cambio en la clase
política con un total de 18 ministros
escogidos nuevo equipo tiene el reto de
recuperar la confianza de los ciudadanos
y responder frente al manejo de la
pandemia del cob y 19 que en perú está
cerca de llegar al millón de contagios